kuu if you could put in a capsule what
enabled you to raise 125,000 dollars on
Kickstarter what would be the most
important factors audience building you
know I never would have launched a
campaign for six figures if I hadn't
spent two years building an online
audience with a website so you know it's
one of those ten years to an overnight
success kind of thing where all the work
you've put in the back you hope you know
helps you do this thing that was the
most ambitious thing I've ever done in
my life as far as you know a Kickstarter
campaign is all or nothing and when you
hit launch and it says $115,000 and it
says zero dollars and zero cents you
know from here to there is a long way to
go but I felt like I had done everything
in my power over the last couple of
years to to build a website and I felt
like enough people knew who I was and
that it was a strong enough project with
some external validation from from Ivy
from Lincoln Center that it was you know
I I felt like if I failed that I would
have done everything I possibly could
and then I wouldn't feel bad about it so
you know the main thing was was building
an audience and the way that I went
about it is different than a lot of
people will as far as you know I was
talking about the craft of filmmaking in
the behind the scenes stuff as opposed
to just this one particular project but
ultimately I think it comes down to that
approach of saying you know Kickstarter
IndieGoGo these things aren't magic you
know you you can make a great video and
but ultimately you have to have a
feeling of you've been working on this
for a long time and that people know who
you are and have are invested in your
success so it's not you know I think the
kicks the Kickstarter campaigns that
don't succeed a lot of the times are
ones where people you know saw somebody
else doing this and thought oh well I
can do that too and they didn't really
understand the amount of work that the
other people did successful campaigns
not only during their campaign but
before it went a lot of that work
happens
you